only on cbs this morning a group of
black former fbi agents are speaking out
to us
about a lack of diversity at the
country's premier law enforcement agency
the cbs news investigative unit spent
several months speaking with dozens of
current and former black fbi agents and
we heard stories
of discrimination and anger anger that
has deepened in the months since
protests for racial justice swept the
country
in an exclusive interview jeff begaye
sat down with four retired black
fbi special agents who are calling for
change
jeff good morning to you
good morning tony as we speak the fbi is
investigating possible
civil rights violations in the killings
of george floyd and brianna taylor
concerned that communities of color
aren't getting a fair shake from the fbi
a group of former agents is now
coming forward exposing what they
believe is a culture of discrimination
within the fbi itself the people that
you have here today we've given more
than half of our professional life in
the service of the fbi
mike mason retired from the fbi as an
executive assistant director
the highest rank a black agent has ever
achieved
after decades as special agents rhonda
glover reese
i had a 34-year career it was awesome
but there needs to be change deborah
evan smith
what we've done in the past really is
not working
and aaron lasher left the fbi in the
last two years
all on their own terms i was in a class
of 38 and i was the only african
american
and you have to realize in my career
everywhere i went
i was the only one they are all members
of a group called the mirror project
and what they seek to change is a number
at the bureau that has remained
virtually the same for decades of the 13
000 fbi special agents around the world
only four percent are black do you think
black agents are held to the same
standard as white agents
uh no no african american in the bureau
is held to the same standards
you have to be twice as good to get just
as far as someone else
in addition to the members of the mirror
project cbs news spoke with more than
two dozen
current and former black agents all of
whom described facing some sort of
racial discrimination
while working inside the fbi do we
bump up against bias racism
absolutely i've experienced um
you know invisibility when you talk
about being a black female
in the fbi sometimes you're not even
seen
these former agents told us that
managers inside the fbi who are
mostly white tend to only promote
individuals who look like themselves
you start to wonder it's because i'm i'm
black i mean what do i need to do
in order to position myself to
be promoted to go to that next level
today of the agents running the fbi's 56
field offices across the country
only three are black a picture is worth
a thousand words
diversity amongst more than gender is
also important
fbi recruiting videos give the
appearance of a bureau made up of a
diverse
talent pool but the agents we spoke with
say
that is not what the fbi is like at all
the fact of the matter is if the fbi is
majority white male
that's who you're going to majority grow
up with and so you're going to be the
beneficiary of that
more than anybody else is it is not
solely the responsibility
of a minority to bring minorities into
the fbi
it's everyone's issue they believe it
matters now more than ever
because the fbi is investigating
potential civil rights violations in the
police killings of george floyd in
minneapolis i cannot breathe
brianna taylor in louisville and the
seven
shots fired into the back of jacob blake
in kenosha wisconsin
as the fbi we are the lead agency to
protect
civil rights do you think that there are
enough black agents working on those
cases right now
no i don't the fbi should actually have
minorities working those cases a white
male
growing up in nebraska is not going to
have the same life experience as
a black female growing up in new york
city do you think
communities of color are getting a fair
shake
from the fbi no members of the mirror
project
sent this letter to director ray last
month
in it they called for the fbi to be held
accountable for its hiring
and promotions practices through formal
reporting to congress
the department of justice and the office
of inspector general
if the leaders the senior executives
if they don't believe in it then it's
not going to happen
the fbi declined our repeated request
for an
interview however they did send us a
statement saying that diversity is a
quote core
value an official also told us that
director ray
is planning to engage members of the
mirror project
it is a rarity for foreign former agents
to speak out
in this manner and yet tomorrow you will
hear from two more
including a former top female agent both
of them
say they faced repeated obstacles
rising through the ranks of the fbi they
say because of their race
gail boy jeff that was very very
powerful to hear what they have to say i
now hope that director ray will sit down
and talk with you
everybody that knows him says that he's
a real reasonable guy
because all of those agents made a very
strong and powerful case about why
changes need to happen at the fbi
i like the one woman who said it's not
just their issue it's everybody's issue
that's right gail and we did by the way
get some cooperation from
agents and employees on the inside
however because they're concerned about
their job security obviously they
weren't about to go on camera
all right all right more to come thank
you very much jeff